joe biden met with world leaders this
weekend to discuss
foreign policy at the g7 conference
and he couldn't even remember the
difference
between the most recent countries that
we have bombed
um we could work together with russia
for example
uh in uh in libya we should be opening
up the
the the passes to be able to go through
provide
provide food assistance and economic
asses i mean
vital assistance to a population that's
in real trouble
i think i'm going to try very much hard
to uh
it is by the way there's places where
i shouldn't be starting off and
negotiating in public here but let me
say it this way
russia has engaged in activities which
are we believe are contrary to
international norms
but they have also
bitten off some real problems they're
going to have trouble chewing on
and for example the rebuilding of
of syria of uh of libya of
you know this is they're there and uh
the
in afghanistan
yep that that was that libya and syria
are different countries though president
biden doesn't recognize that he's so
this vibrant man got more votes than
anyone ever in the history of voting or
he's probably got more votes than assad
joe biden's performance was a
laughingstock as was the whole g7 summit
but it won't matter because members of
the ruling elite never seem to face
consequences for their actions from blm
race hustlers and hoax artists
to the big tech oligarchs who just
censored a u.s senator just happened
to the self-loving jeff tubin getting
reinstated on cnn after pleasuring
himself on a zoom call
but we will hold them to account i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from socially
dangerous element who says it sounds as
if
people who don't believe in the concept
of sin are using the term
whiteness as a stand-in for sin that's
true that's exactly what they're doing
the difference of course between the
traditional christian understanding of
sin
and the current woke understanding of
whiteness as sin
is that in christianity there's
redemption and
in wokeness there ain't no redemption
which is why you have the people who
view whiteness as a sin saying as they
did in that major medical journal last
week
that this is a disease this is a
terrible problem and it requires a
permanent cure permanent cure you say
what does that mean i don't know it
doesn't sound great
you know if jeffrey tubin has taught us
anything it's that you've got to protect
your data
online that's where expressvpn comes in
did you ever read the fine print that
appears when you start browsing in
incognito mode well it says if only
jeffrey tube
had read this it says that your activity
might still be visible to your employer
or your school or your internet service
provider to really
stop people from seeing the sites that
you visit you need to do
what i would strongly recommend what i
use all the time expressvpn
now maybe you know i'm not saying you're
doing the jeffrey dubin thing
i'm saying you're looking at sites that
maybe are not very popular with the
ruling
elite you know really nefarious
shameful so i'm talking about
dailywire.com you know what i mean well
without expressvpn every site that you
visit could be logged
by the administrator of that network
even when you're in incognito mode
do you really want your liberal parents
to see that you've been looking at
ben shapiro's show absolutely not no you
can't do it expressvpn is a great app
it protects your data one button you tap
to connect it's so simple
stop letting strangers invade your
online privacy protect yourself
at expressvpn.com michael use my link at
expressvpn.com
michael to get three extra months for
free that's exp or essvpn.com
michael to learn more joe biden was a
complete laughing stock
if anyone were laboring under the
misapprehension
that joe biden is commanding the world
stage or the national stage or he's the
strongest leader in the history with the
greatest mandate to rule or whatever
they're telling us
i think that fell apart over the the g7
summit
the the other leaders of the world
literally were laughing at him
because joe biden couldn't remember what
was just said
moments prior
those who have just joined us being some
pretty spectacular weather
uh with them prime minister moses uh
president ramaphosa president moon
in just a minute
[Music]
oh gosh it's so awkward so boris johnson
prime minister
of the uk is and announcing everyone
who's here
pretty much but and then biden
interrupts he's
kind of comes back into the conversation
he really kind of wakes up and he says
and the president of south africa and
then bojo
he's debating you can hear he's debating
like yes uncle joe i already
i already introduced the president of
south africa yes yes the president of
ibrika is just as well as a
as i said moments ago oh you already
said it
and then everyone laughs at him and then
he laughs
later still not quite getting the joke
really embarrassing stuff
you know i don't care what the rest of
the world thinks of the united states
during the bush years bush ii during the
trump years
democrats rent their garments and
gnashed their teeth because they said oh
no the world is laughing at us and
first of all i don't think that was true
of of those presidents certainly not of
trump
and uh but even if so who cares i don't
really you know it doesn't bother me
what bothers me is the advancement of
the national interest that's what i care
about on the global stage
and so that that's fine the the problem
here is that joe biden not only is a
laughingstock to the rest of the world
but he is not advancing the american
national interest in fact he's doing
everything i think
to undermine that in favor of an elite
transnational liberal consensus that's
dominated our politics
for more than a quarter of a century to
show you how out of touch
these people are with the constituencies
that they rule
just consider how they all walked up
and met one another they framed this
bizarre sort of
video on the beach and as they were
walking up to greet one another
they they poked their elbows you know
they wouldn't they didn't shake hands
but they did their the elbow thing but
what was strange about this stupid
elbow you know where you bump the elbows
is that they
other than trudeau
the rest of them the the man layer of
the bunch i'm damning with faint praise
did not have masks on so they were
acknowledging yes
kovitt is over they've all been
inoculated i imagine
but they were still doing the bump they
were still doing this elbow bump
this conveys two
very disturbing facts about our global
elite
people think oh it's just this little
minor thing they're doing the elbow bump
instead of shaking hands no
it conveys two really disturbing facts
one
they think it's kind of funny they they
think the whole thing is kind of oh he
here again this is what we're doing
hehehe look we're going to bump elbows
yeah we shut down the global economy
and we suspended everyone's political
rights and we closed churches teehee
isn't this so funny
isn't it they're giggling i mean you can
see them sort of laughing oh my gosh
you know it's the way that whenever you
get on a zoom call now you have to joke
about the fact that you're on a zoom
call but that's the same thing with the
elbows
the second thing that's disturbing about
this
is that the ruling elite
whether they know it or not i'm not
saying these are the most self-aware
people on earth but
whether they know it or not are
conveying their belief
that the rituals that bind us together
in society
are just totally arbitrary they're
completely
random and we can change them
willy-nilly without any effect
using our own faculties of reason so yes
for a very very long time we've all
shaken hands that's the the way that we
greet one another
in society but you know who needs to do
that now we're gonna bump elbows why
because these seven weirdos decided that
we're gonna do that
so because these weirdos who happen to
have
positions of power right now are
deciding it we all have to change our
customs and the rest of the world and
that's perfectly fine
they'll force us to do it there's no
there's no particular reason that
customs have developed
we're just going to go along with the
new normal
i don't think i'm reading too much into
it i mean these symbols convey something
and you know words are symbols ac these
sort of actions and gestures are symbols
and those convey their understanding of
the symbolize their understanding of the
world i talk about this by the way at
great length
in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now for pre-order
i believe that book there we go it's a
little delayed but that's fine
i believe that book is out in eight
days we are now just over one week away
if you want a signed first edition copy
head on over to premiere collectibles
and get that today what we have seen
certainly for the past several decades
but we're seeing now accelerating
is the fact that for the elites there
are basically no consequences
they shut down the world for no reason
oops
they were wrong about basically every
aspect of this
virus in their predictions and in some
cases they outright lied to us as in the
case of fouchy
whoopsie daisy what you gonna do about
it too bad gotta move on
the clearest example of this of course
is jeffrey toobin i think
jeffrey tubin single-handedly you might
say
exposed the corruption of this
elite group in the media and in politics
and
it's all kind of part of the same blob
this guy gets caught doing something
that would see anyone else ostracized
from society
and he's allowed back on the air jeffrey
toobin joined cnn
it was what you might say a very
touching interview
jeffrey toobin was there speaking to i
think this woman's name is allison
camarada i
sort of forget the names of the liberal
journalists but i think that's who this
one is she's one of the gals at cnn
and it's her task to bring jeffrey tubin
back into the mainstream
take a listen hi jeffrey hello allison
it's been a while it has been a while
indeed
i feel like we should address um what's
happened in the months
since we've seen you since some of our
viewers may not know
what has happened so i guess i'll recap
i'll do the honors help yourself
okay in october
you were on a zoom call with your
colleagues from the new yorker magazine
everyone took a break for several
minutes during which time
you were caught masturbating on camera
you were subsequently fired from that
job after 27 years of working there
and you since then have been on leave
from cnn
do i have all that right um you got it
all right sad to say
so incredibly awkward though jeffrey
toobin really
um did not advance his own cause here i
think
because he uh the one thing he said
as she was outlining all of these
charges she said okay so i'm just going
to lay it out right
he says uh help yourself
not the best choice of words in the
particular discussion that we're all
having here very very awkward discussion
then jeffrey toobin gets into his
explanation
well obviously i wasn't thinking very
well or very much
and it was something that was
inexplicable
to me i think one point i i wouldn't
exactly say in my defense because
nothing is really in my defense
i didn't think i was on the call i
didn't think
other people could see me you thought
that you had turned off your camera
correct
i thought that i had turned off the zoom
call now that's not a defense this was
deeply moronic and indefensible
but i mean that that is part of that
that is part of the story
that is part of the story so it is an
excuse that he's making and this is
so interesting because this excuse i
think will resonate with parts of the
left and the right
but it shows you how hollow it is namely
saying look i thought i was doing this
this bad thing in private
so it's not an excuse but i thought i
was doing it in private but have you
ever considered i know in our liberal
permissive society we're not allowed to
say this
have you ever considered that maybe you
shouldn't be doing that in private
that maybe the reason you feel shame of
it being exposed
is because the thing is bad to do
in and of itself jeffrey two been
explaining
so much more in his defense of himself
now when things get a little crazy out
there as
as anyone who turns on the news will see
it's very good
to invest in some precious metals that's
why i would recommend checking out acre
gold
acre lets you subscribe to gold bars for
as little as 30
a month you pay each month once your
gold stash reaches the price of their
gold bars
they will discreetly ship acre gold to
your house acre has a new 100
a month subscription to a 5 gram gold
bar acre keeps you updated on your gold
stash
every month and ships once you reach the
price threshold
with acre taking physical delivery of
that gold means that it is safe and
sound
and in your hands i have always really
enjoyed investing in precious metals
it's also a great hedge against
inflation
which you're already seeing right now
quite a lot with gas lumber and food
prices
you don't need to come out of pocket all
at once you know investing in physical
gold can be a very expensive task if you
don't do it the right way
but you get started with acre right now
for just 30 bucks a month go to
getacregold.com
knowles start investing in physical gold
today make sure you go to this url
because acre
is giving away a gold bar to qualify for
the giveaway tweet or post why you
should be the recipient and mention at
get underscore acre
that's getacregold.com knowles and thank
you akergold for supporting the show
jeffrey toobin the self-loving cnn legal
analyst
is back on tv they've mainstreamed him
again it's very awkward
the cnn hosts have to explain what he
did
he's giving these excuses and his big
excuses
i didn't know that i was on air
i you know i didn't or rather i didn't
know i was on the zoom call i didn't
know people could see me
this shows you how weak our moral
discourse has become
all sin and fall short of the glory of
god however
there used to be an understanding in the
society that you are never
alone someone is always watching even in
the privacy of your darkest chamber
the good lord above is watching people
can see what you're doing you are
accountable
even for your private actions but what
what we have now
developed in this country in our secular
and permissive society
is this idea that in the privacy of your
own home and in
in your own private life you can do
whatever you want and we've considered
this to be the height of liberty even
though it's not liberty it's
licentiousness and our founding fathers
made a big distinction between the two
they're actually polar opposites
if you have a country in which
everybody is doing all sorts of bad
things in private they don't even feel
shame for it
then you're going to get a country that
has a bad public sphere as well
because the public sphere is going to
just be
all these private people doing things
together jeffrey toobin concludes
his excuse i have spent the seven
subsequent months miserable months in my
life i can certainly
confess trying to be a better person i
mean in therapy
trying to do some public service working
in a food bank which i certainly am
going to continue to do
working on a new book about the oklahoma
city bombing but i
am trying to become the kind of person
that people can trust again i actually
give him some credit here but i think
that he and the cnn audience probably
don't understand
the the reasoning that that he's
advancing here
why if you get caught doing that thing
on zoom with your colleagues
why would you work in a food bank how is
that gonna
i get the therapy system in therapy for
whatever is compulsive
compulsions but why the food bank
because what he's saying is
i'm giving in to sin and vice and when
you give in to sin advice
that makes you a worse person so now i'm
going to try to do good things
acts of charity pursue the virtues and
that's going to make me a good person
and good people can be trusted now i
don't know how genuine he's being i mean
this might just be a way to try to
mainstream his career but maybe maybe
he's being straight
i don't know the point is
what we do in private will affect
our public's square and the so much of
the right no longer acknowledges that
because we've
gone crazy with these bumper sticker
slogans of
individual rights and that we don't
understand even what that meant
in the context of the founding fathers
because we don't know anything because
we've got people who don't have any
credibility telling it to us
speaking of your responsibility in the
news
newspaper in texas the austin american
statesman
said on saturday that it will not
publish the description
that local law enforcement gave them of
a man
suspected of shooting 13 people
a guy shows up shoots 13 people on
friday night
and the newspaper will not publish the
description of that
suspect because it could quote could be
harmful in perpetrating stereotypes
which now i think everyone has an image
of what this person is but you're not
allowed to say it
editor's note police have only released
a vague description of the suspect
shooter
as of saturday morning the austin
american statesman
is not including the description as it
is too vague at this time
to be useful in identifying the shooter
and such publication could be harmful
and perpetrating
perpetuating stereotypes if more
detailed information is released we'll
update our reporting
so what does the suspect look like well
according to the austin police
department
he's a black male with dreadlocks
wearing a black shirt and a skinny build
so he's a black guy so they won't
publish it if he were a white guy they
would have published it
remember when george zimmerman and
trayvon martin
got into got into an altercation it
wasn't even just that it was
completely use of force on the side of
zimmerman and trayvon martin was not
using force at all you saw there were
lots of injuries on zimmerman too
but because in that case and this was
years ago because they initially thought
zimmerman was a white guy they published
it a white man hunting down a black
teenager
and they pretended that he that trayvon
martin was like six years old and
remember they
posted that very young photo of him and
then the narrative fell apart because
zimmerman's not a white guy he's a
hispanic guy
and then they tried they redefined it in
the times they said he's a white
hispanic as they were doing anything
they could
to grab onto their racial narrative
namely
the one that lebron james for example
advances that black men can't leave
their homes without being hunted down
by racist whites in this story
that doesn't work that the narrative
falls apart in the face of these facts
and so the newspaper says no we can't do
that because that would advance
harmful stereotypes
this shows you a racial double standard
that is uh when the facts contradict it
there are no consequences
another example at wayne state
university a black student at wayne
state university
in michigan claimed that she was part of
two separate acts of vandalism
because she is black when i saw this
story i looked at it and i said you know
i would bet a lot of money that that
didn't happen
now the left of course assumed that it
did because the left
believes that america is a racist white
supremacist terrible place where
black people can't leave their homes
without being hunted down we of course
know that that is not true we know that
the only type of
racism that is tolerated by the law and
by society and even encouraged in some
ways by the culture
is against white people into a lesser
degree against asian people so you just
look at that story and you say no that
didn't happen
turns out we were right there so here's
this woman's claim and the
the irony of course and this happens in
a lot of these race hoaxes
is that the the woman making the claims
doesn't even look particularly black on
february 16th
right in the middle of black history
month somebody decided to vandalize my
door
there was a black lives matter sticker
on it and they threw eggs at my door
i reported it to my community director
and to my r.a
nothing happened the only thing that
happened was my ra sent a message out to
our floor
saying that if we wanted to be
discriminatory to take it off campus and
off our floor
it happened again on march 1st last
monday
this time it was much more severe they
basically
got every single inch of my door with
eggs they got um
my pride flag particularly the black
lives matter sticker
was what they were aiming for um at that
point i
contacted the head of housing and i
basically said that i wanted to leave
they were coming for me they were coming
for my dog
all because i was a black student living
in their space we want these people to
be held accountable
we want people to know that black
students will not be silenced
in their space of education you can't
remove us from our homes and we will be
getting educated
now if you listen carefully first of all
i never believe this for a second but if
you listen carefully
she says you know they were throwing it
at all my stickers my pride sticker my
this my that but they were especially
aiming at the black lives matter sticker
not that they especially hit the black
lives matter but they were aiming how
does she know what they were aiming at
to to know how they were aiming
rather than just what they hit you would
have to be the one who threw the eggs
yourself which is what appears to have
happened here now she is the
the main suspect in this jessie smellet
all over again i actually detail
probably a dozen or more of these race
hoaxes in my upcoming book speeches
controlling words controlling mind
available now for pre-order
uh i i mean i have many members of my
family
who look darker than this girl
right and yet she is saying that i in
particular are being targeted for the
anti-black racism in this country
why she's saying this because racial
grievance has
currency it carries social currency
if you can claim in any way to be a
member of an aggrieved group
you get certain privileges in school
in the culture from the government you
will get certain
advantages and if you can't claim that
kind of racial agreements you'll be at a
disadvantage
so she lied she made it up and now she
got caught
many more people will do it racial
grievance is big
business right now you're seeing it in
the infighting in the blm movement
so you know we've covered blm by large
mansions
and we've we've covered the head of that
patrice cullers who recently had to step
down because she was caught
buying multiple gigantic homes some in
beverly hills some millions of dollars
and it became clear that this was a
grift this was a con this was a way to
i think they raised 90 million dollars
last year for blm they have 60 million
cash on hand
and now some of the other breakaway blm
groups blm groups that are not
under the umbrella of the national
organization they want a piece of the
action
namely michael michael brown's father's
you remember michael brown was that
kid he was a young a teenager who had
just robbed a convenience store and then
he was
he charged a cop grabbed the cop's gun
and then he was shot and he it was
dis dishonestly reported that he had his
hands up and he said hands up don't
shoot that didn't happen
confirmed by grand jury by multiple
autopsies that just didn't happen
but now the family of michael brown is
asking
to get a little piece of the action from
the blm national organization
you can hear more about all sorts of
this kind of stuff on the candace owens
podcast right now download and subscribe
to candace the audio podcast on apple
spotify
or wherever you get your podcast be sure
to leave a five star review
to keep her podcast trending in the
charts the same way that her name is
always trending on twitter
also my friend georgia howe the daily
wire's very own
is a former teacher and a liberal who
saw the ideological indoctrination
sweeping the nation
and bravely took a stand against it in
her new show office hours she offers us
her unique perspective as a former
leftist which you can now get anywhere
you go
with the office hours podcast subscribe
and download office hours with georgia
how on apple podcasts or whichever
platform you
you choose and get ready for the
ultimate listening experience no matter
where you
are we'll be right back
the race hustlers are fighting with one
another and they're not fighting over
justice and they're not fighting over
philosophy
they're fighting over cold hard cash
because the blm national organization
raised tens of millions of dollars
almost 100 million dollars and the
smaller blm groups want a piece of the
action so
the the most notable person in this
fight is the father of michael brown
a new york city group is is focused on
this but also the father of michael
brown
in ferguson he was the you know the
teenager who got into the altercation
with the cop on the street
so when i when i
heard that michael brown senior was
going after
the blm organization i i never thought
that this would be this guy waking up
and
deciding that actually this racial
grievance is this is a bad thing and we
need to change our tactics no
i knew it was always going to be just
that he wanted a little more money out
of it
and turns out i was right there's a
memoir out
by the mother of michael brown
and by the i don't think they were
married but by the
girlfriend of michael brown senior and
this this
book is called speak the truth and shame
the devil
you'll notice that whenever these poor
kids
are caught up or teenagers or whatever
are caught up in in an officer-involved
shooting
and no matter how justified the shooting
all of a sudden family members come up
and come out of the woodwork
family members and they say we demand
justice and what they really demand is a
paycheck and that's what we're seeing
with michael brown senior
all the evidence if if
michael brown's mother is to be believed
is that this guy was a real piece of
work
according to the memoir he was a violent
abuser
this the father uh he forced a shotgun
into michael brown's mother's mouth
during a fight so far down her throat
that she
choked uh she writes in her memoir that
that she could hear her two chil their
two children
with michael brown senior crying
downstairs
as this man was pointing a gun at her at
one time
he smashed the windshield of her car
with his fist
he repeatedly beat her in front of the
children he cheated on her he's a
deadbeat he refused to get a job
all according to the memoir and then one
time right in front of of michael brown
jr he took her and threw her into a tv
now
i'm just going to take this woman at her
word i don't see any reason
not to believe it and and michael brown
senior has not done a very good job
denying these charges
it makes you feel pretty bad for these
kids for someone like michael brown so
michael brown was committing crimes too
michael brown reached for the officer's
gun in ferguson i don't think the
officer had any
any alternative than to do what he did
however this kid obviously comes from a
horrible place because his father
according to all evidence is a complete
and utter degenerate
and now the father is demanding justice
in millions and millions of dollars
all according to racial grievance so
this guy a compl by all accounts just a
complete
deadbeat a complete drain on society and
worse
violent abuser and yet he's going to be
held up
as a hero if you read the mainstream
media accounts and you don't read this
woman's memoir
this guy he's the poor aggrieved father
and the
victim himself of racial injustice no
the reason that they do this is because
he is useful
to the current ruling elite and so
they're going to use him
to push their narrative
and when they come up with a new
narrative they'll
find some new guy to push that same
narrative it doesn't matter the facts on
the ground
they won't be held to account the lack
of consequences for elites
and for preferred groups brings about
huge injustices maybe you saw this story
this was a few weeks ago
an 18 year old guy was caught on camera
on a little nighttime camera over a bed
or over a crib
kidnapping and murdering a four-year-old
boy
so he go you can see it's really
terrifying he goes into the room
nabs this kid out of bed he's sleeping
next to his brother four-year-old boy
and then the boy sometime later is found
beaten to death dead on the street
the suspect's name the suspect who we
saw on camera
is der darren ronnelle brown
18 years old strongly suspected of
murdering this four-year-old boy cash
guernan
thankfully he's been charged with
capital murder which carries a life
sentence or possibly the death penalty
now how did it get this bad the reason i
bring this up is not even to talk about
the current charges
obviously the guy deserves to fry
there's no question about it
and it would be good for him to fry it
would be rehabilitative to him
to contemplate his own his own eternal
soul
but this isn't the first time that he's
done something
like this this guy darren rennell brown
is also accused of walking into a dallas
home
on february 8th and grabbing a young
child the police say he broke in and he
rummaged around
then he punched the homeowner after the
homeowner confronted him
he'd picked up the man's two-year-old
granddaughter the man was able to get
the girl back
and then and this is the weirdest part
the homeowner didn't want to press
charges at the time
he told the police that brown had
apologized to him later now first of all
the police should have pre i mean the
d.a should have pressed charges anyway
no matter what the homeowner wants
if some guy busts into someone's house
and grabs a two-year-old girl
and then there's an altercation to get
the girl back and then
and then the homeowner says actually
never mind no harm no foul
the d.a it is their responsibility to
press charges
but what you're going to hear from a lot
of the prison reform crowd and all the
people who say actually it was society
that made this guy
beat and kill a four-year-old child or
try to steal a two-year-old child
what they're going to say is look we
need mercy we're a merciful and
compassionate society
and in our mercy and our compassion
we're going to let this guy off the hook
where's the mercy and compassion for
cass garnet where's the mercy and
compassion for his family where's the
mercy and compassion for this
two-year-old girl
that thankfully he didn't manage to
steal her
where's that mercy and compassion
these are real consequences here but
because
i'm frankly i'm shocked that they
released the guy's
description or i that's going to advance
harmful stereotypes right
according to the austin statesman it's
gonna you're not allowed to do that
but this has horrible the the bizarre
racial narrative that the left has
grabbed onto in this country
is having horrible effects for people of
all races for justice in the country
and it doesn't matter no consequences
what's no there'll be no consequences
for the d.a who didn't push charges
none at all i hope there are
consequences for this this
guy darren ronnell brown maybe there
will be maybe there won't
now the the racial narrative that
they're pushing of course
is uh that as the commenter observed at
the top of the show
that whiteness is a sort of stand-in for
sin and that's why it's a we need a
permanent cure to it
and we need to abolish it and this is
what we're told now in
corporate boardrooms in university
campuses
there is legal anti-white racism you're
seeing it from the biden administration
the biden administration's
coveted relief package almost 2 trillion
dollars
has several provisions that discriminate
against people on the basis of race
including one that provided forgiveness
of the paycheck protection program
this is a program to small business
owners to keep their their workers on
staff
it would forgive the the loans
for socially disadvantaged farmers
and what that meant was non-white
farmers so if you're a white farmer
you have to pay back huge loans if
you're a non-white farmer you don't
that is racial discrimination it's
specifically anti-white racial
discrimination so in april
the texas agriculture commissioner sid
miller sued the biden administration
and said that this violates title vi of
the civil rights act it obviously does
a federal judge right now has ruled that
the usda's
use of race-based criteria in the
administration of this program does
violate the right to equal protection
under the law but the usda is fighting
back and they're going to try to advance
this and they're going to make all sorts
of arguments
that actually in the name of racial
justice you need to
punish white farmers and you need to
reward non-white farmers
why why are they doing it i suspect
they're doing that
because they they
recognize that this sort of of a policy
this sort of a narrative will upend
america
if you can say that america
and the people who built america and
uh the people who look like the people
who built america
and the people who are in any ways
descendants that they're evil that
they're rotten to the core
then you provide an opportunity to upend
society this is a process
that has been spelled out by very
prominent leftist theorists
and has gone down through the ages a
process that i spell out my upcoming
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds i suspect that most
people
if you presented this to them most
people of any race if you presented it
to them
you go up to a hispanic guy or a black
guy or an asian guy you say hey
do you think it's fair to punish white
people and to reward black people
i suspect the majority of everyone would
say no i don't think that's fair
maybe some people would say yeah damn
right it's fair but i i bet you that the
majority of people
across demographics would say no that
doesn't seem right
and yet that is the rule i bet you if
you pulled the majority of america he
said do you think this is right they
would say no
so so how is it that the actual
governing policies
of our democracy seem so different
than what the people would actually like
to see
why is it because the elites
are not representative of the people
who are the elites is it is it the
senators no i don't think so
i don't think is it the you know the
president not to a degree sure is it the
this is it that
the elites are part of the liberal
establishment they can be in media they
can be in
universities they can be in government
they can be in what corporations they
can be in big tech
they have much more power than say a
republican senator here's the proof of
that republican senator ron johnson
just posted a youtube video we can't
play it we are not permitted to play if
we play this video
we will be taken off of youtube
in this video he opined about the use of
hydroxychloroquine and ivermectin
these were medicines that have been said
uh are useful
to treat covid19 doctors have said this
scientists have said this but not the
leftist scientists
and not the politically approved
scientists so ron johnson a u.s senator
goes out and says hey we should we
should talk about this
we should talk about the use of these
drugs youtube
takes him down nobody ever elected
youtube nobody ever
uh put youtube on a ballot and said yes
and in youtube by the way
as part of google controls the flow of
information around our public sphere
they are the place where democracy
happens right where where politics
happens
they say no a duly elected sitting u.s
senator sorry
you're out now
you're going to hear the squishes say
that this is actually actually wonderful
there's nothing more american than
allowing a handful of woke oligarchs to
con
to dominate and control our politics
that's that's what james madison
intended darn it
that's freedom of build your own google
or whatever but obviously obviously
people have a political right in a
self-governing republic
to have a say over how information moves
around the sphere we're allowed to
say that we should be able to speak
without being impeded by these woke
oligarchs
but it's very confusing for the squishes
because they have been just
totally brainwashed by 20 years or so of
stupid republican talking points
which you can read about you read about
that whole process in my opinion
speechless controlling words
controlling minds who
is the misinformer here who's the
conspiracy theorist
so many things that we were told with
certainty by the liberal elites
have turned out not to be true remember
when
you could be banned from
social media for saying that very likely
the covet virus leaked from the wuhan
lab
remember you could be banned for saying
that we said it anyway
and fortunately we survived but a lot of
other people did not on social media
well now that would appear to be the
most likely explanation
the uh fact-checking websites initially
said this is false ten pinocchios this
is totally false they've had to edit
their fact checks because the facts
apparently turn out to be
true who are the misinformers here it
seems to me that it's
the liberal elites this from dr steven
quay
who uh points out in this question of
whether
covid is a natural virus or not he says
the odds that this is a totally natural
virus
one in a billion i'm a scientist i've
looked at this from a straight
scientific point of view not you know
personalities
and they're just so many signatures and
so many events that are consistent with
a lab leak there's there's literally no
fact that is of
that we know of that is similar to a
previous
natural zoonosis so um you know
my analysis gets into the one in the
billion
chance here that this could have come
from nature virologists have done work
over the last 20 30 years and there's
probably
seven or eight jumps from an animal
virus to a human
every year in asia they burn out they
don't they don't cause any sort of
disease
there is one lab leak per year that's
documented over the last 30 years in
asia
so it's an eight to one ratio out of the
box so uh
i you know for for january 2020 when i
heard that there was a wet market
associated with this i was saying okay
that sounds familiar
and then i heard that that the the the
the only bsla 4 laboratory
and the place where 60 of all the
coronavirus research that's been
published
in the world comes from the institute of
virology
is you know three kilometers from the
pla hospital where the first patient was
that switches your that switches your
probabilities you know overnight
instantly
sorry sounds too scientific for me i
don't th that's too much for youtube i
don't think you're allowed to say that
sort of thing
who are the misinformers who are the
conspiracy theorists
what they told us from the beginning
even at the point of censorship has been
proven
wrong time and time and time again are
they going to face consequences
no way i do think
there is some glimmering hope that this
ruling liberal elite
will eventually be held to account at
least to some agree
degree the glimmering hope
florida baby florida and south dakota
the americas of america the land of the
free
where we can still breathe the sweet air
of freedom
the economies those two states are not
only
back to where they were before kovid
they're actually better they're stronger
than they were before covid
right now the economy of south dakota is
performing at 106
of its pre-coveted strength florida
performing at 101 percent of its
pre-covet strength other states tend to
be a little more conservative
states like west virginia nevada montana
iowa arizona so not totally you know
completely red states but still a little
more conservative
they're they're doing well they're still
below their pre-coveted strength but
south dakota and florida
two states that were basically open the
whole time took a very
skeptical approach to all the lockdowns
and and
basically just kept society moving uh
they're doing better why
i can just tell you anecdotally because
every event is happening in south dakota
and
and much more so in florida i've been to
florida this year
probably six times why because every
political event that is allowed to occur
is happening in florida and i was in
south dakota a few weeks ago
because some political events are
allowed there too and other there are no
political events really in new york
because new york is still shut down
or california or anywhere else i'm about
to go back to florida
in just a few weeks people are
voting with their feet to a certain
degree
and i mean you can see it here i'm
living in tennessee i used to live in
california
covid was the straw that broke the
camel's back and we got out of there
that is a hope the hope is that you see
these sensible places uh
growing in strength and growing in
confidence now that that will
lead to what many have called the
balkanization of america
or it could lead to that and that could
create some national problems
but the states themselves are going to
be asserting their
own rights and that's a good thing it's
great that we can test it you can see
actually florida
did much better than the places that
locked down
now there's a downside to that too
though which is
i don't think this is the permanent
solution i think that
ultimately when these states get a
little too free when these states
get a little too sensible the federal
government is going to come in i mean
this is
this is so much of what you're seeing
with the growth of the public health
bureaucracy
the growth of the the racial grievance
ideology that is
is often enforced at the federal level
and the growth
of these corporations that have more
political power than
many elected officials which operate as
mitch mcconnell said like a sort of
parallel government
they're going to clamp down and some
people are going to try to stand strong
like christy gnome is going to try to
some degree or
ron desantis is doing a pretty good job
at it but ultimately i do fear
that even given a handful of republican
really tough conservative states
the liberal establishment is just so
strong it is not enough to say well just
go to your own states and we'll just
have federalism no
we've got to gain national power too
we've got to push back
you know the federal and cultural uh
the federal policies rather have such
huge cultural effect because they've got
so many resources i mean you know during
covet
the federal government puts out all
these extremely
abundant ample unemployment benefits
it's part of the reason right now that
employers are having a tough job
getting people to come back to work is
because they've had very good benefits
so there's a report out now
according to axios that uh street gangs
and foreign criminal syndicates may have
stolen
up to half of the unemployment benefits
paid out during
the coronavirus lockdowns half of it
half of your tax money
massive massive transfer of wealth
stolen by criminals
is is anybody going to pay for that is
anybody going to be held to
no oopsie daisy whoops sorry
sorry this is what we've heard for
decade of pundit oh we got rid of your
we shipped your all your manufacturing
jobs overseas oops yeah i
we sort of had to or whatever sorry too
bad
deal with it oops your communities have
been totally hollowed out by drugs
and you're end up ended by mass
immigration without any sort of
assimilation whoopsie daisy yep that's
just the way it is
nope no accountability oops we gave half
your money to criminals yeah
oops sorry whoopsie daisy
the rnc is very slowly very slowly
starting i think kind of to wake up to
this
in terms of the presidential debate in
2024
the rnc is now saying they might skip
network television debates if they are
not dramatically overhauled
this is a very good sign not because
this is going to be the game-changing
issue the presidential debates
you know to some degree who cares but
it's a symbol of the larger problem
that the right plays on the left's
field according to the left's rules the
fact
that republican candidates for president
especially during the primaries but even
during the general would go
on to these leftist network debates
and let leftists dictate the
the priorities of their own party or
even of the general election
is insane obviously these networks are
not objective and they're not
nonpartisan but we continue to play
along with that
and as republicans play along with that
the only effect
that they can possibly have is to be the
court jester in the kingdom of
liberalism
the only thing that they're going to do
is legitimize the ruling liberal
establishment that is
accountable to nobody and that's it
and that's all there is it's even worse
than doing nothing
because they're giving credence to the
idea that we actually have a functioning
two-party system in the country when in
fact we don't we have a liberal
establishment and we have
a group of people that basically try
to you know put up a show of opposition
but really just go along to get along
before we go
i've only got 33 seconds left i've got
to point out you know aoc
made this whole claim that donald trump
kept her abuela's
relief money in puerto rico away from
her and she was living in squalor
and then matt walsh and the daily wire
crew over here raised a hundred thousand
dollars to fix abuela's roof
and then aoc on behalf of abuela called
gofundme and shut down the whole thing
and kind of proved the point that that
it was never about
aoc's grandmother or anything like that
it was just a cheap talking point well
headline right now from aoc's aunt this
is in the daily mail
it's a problem here in puerto rico not
with washington aoc's aunt says trump is
not to blame for lack of aid to the
struggling island
after the congresswoman bashed the
former president for damage to her
grandmother's home
i was just totally made up the whole
abuela thing was just completely
contrived
and fake the arguments that aoc made
about it just not true she just lied
and won't face
any consequences for it we're all we're
all jeffrey tubin now
aren't we we're all you know i think
pleasuring oneself on a zoom call is
probably the
the most precise description i've ever
heard for our ruling elite how sad is
that i'm michael knowles the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show